あの最近や間に空に向かおうとしている自分がいます
今回はちょっと続けて上に行く系なんですけどもう風船ヘリコプター組み立て簡単見
たらわかると思うんですけどもう風前つけると空に飛んでっかヘリコプターでござい
ます
799んって書いて動画公開されているらしいですね作り方は超簡単で組み立て図
膨らましてくっつけたら飛んでいくということでございますちょっとやってみましょう
思ってきた砲撃と思う人もできた
裏まして
よしそれを空気が抜けないようにプロペラにつけたらうっ
ok もいけるを入れなきゃっぽい巨鯉巨もう持ってるやつもとにはスコア
ええええええ
6爪強いこれ免税よたこが来てくれたん
えっうーんまあ空だって超も泣けないちょっともう追記と向けていますぴゅーんでそう
いうことなのね
きたきたきた岩瀬岩崎ますうーん
[音楽]
eme
ああああああ
あってまってまってちゅももだけですうん
衛兵
ブーフ
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーバーし
そんなハムハムしてん re
は腐れやってみんんん
はい俺無理ではないというふうに見てもらった通りこの風船7分に大きな風船をつける
とめちゃくちゃ飛ぶんじゃないかという国の予想でございますまあ体験ぐらいは行き
たいですね
いい時はで壁の部屋数つけるとめちゃくちゃ飛ぶんじゃねーか強そうでございますか
やってみましょう
ん
[音楽]
んなんでくるよきん
場所が悪かったのかな多すぎたからこれ自体に何か効果動的に変えるわけじゃないもん
上でだよじゃあ赤い風船は口が大きすぎるのと風船時代が重すぎて止まらなかったんで
ちょっと中間をとってこのサイズの風船で膨らましてみますこれだったとブー
これだったら多分飛ぶ気がしますスクラムしますまずこれでとばたかった今日企画どう
するオレで終わりですよ
でかいでしょいけるぞこれいけるいければ水けどいける口ですはいじゃあ行きますませ
ん
[音楽]
男は諦めずに
何度も風先輩危険を飛ばそうとスター無理だっ
そして最後には悲劇が男を追った
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
えっ
ています
th